germany will
do justice to its responsibilities that
is the message coming today from german
chancellor olaf schultz he used an
address before the country's parliament
to double down on his government's
commitment to supporting ukraine and
other international allies
in a wide-ranging speech the chancellor
said that the european union and nato
have joined forces like never before to
fight against russian imperialism
he said that germany knows from its own
history that alliances are important and
that germany remains a reliable partner
in the biggest security challenge in
europe for decades germany as the most
densely populated and largest country in
the eu is doing justice to its
responsibility
taking responsibility not just for its
own security but also that of its allies
two weeks ago when i was in the baltic
states i made it clear that an attack on
the baltic states would be an attack on
all of us
all right let's pull in our political
correspondent simon young he's been
following that speech for us simon
yes security was at the forefront of the
chancellor's speech there but i mean i
was hearing not just security for
germany but um germany's responsibility
vis-a-vis it's it's allies when we're
talking about security what did you hear
well that's right brent olav schultz
repeated a commitment that he made back
at the start of the war
in ukraine
saying that we will uh protect every
centimeter of nato territory and he says
that germany is doing that by
beefing up its own
military spending but also by sending
troops and materiel to nato's
eastern flank
and showing its commitment that way but
of course also uh by
the support that it's given to ukraine
both
financial uh and increasingly in the
form of direct military support as well
simon
the chancellor today he tried to quash
the idea that he is moving too slowly
on helping ukraine did he achieve what
he wanted to
well i guess that will depend on wider
perceptions there certainly are plenty
of people here in germany um opposition
politicians and others who i think that
uh the progress has been too slow and
too
hesitant uh will other world leaders uh
you know give germany the credit that
olaf schultz thinks it deserves uh we'll
have to wait and see yeah he's got a
week of summit meetings coming up in
particular the nato summit here in
germany at the weekend and the beginning
of next week
and we may hear more there particularly
president zielenski of ukraine himself
will be part of that nato summit by
video link
and now that the first heavy weapons
from germany have actually begun to
arrive in ukraine perhaps some of the
criticism
of germany's cautious approach
will die down
our political correspondent simon young
with the latest tonight here in berlin
simon thank you
well in his speech today german
chancellor schultz also said that
ukraine has every right to defend itself
adding that it is our duty germany's
duty to support ukraine as best we can
germany has faced international
criticism however for its initial
reluctance to supply ukraine with
weapons and then for the time that it
took to deliver them
the german panzer bits its 5000 one of
the most sophisticated artillery systems
in the world
almost five months after russia's
invasion of ukraine seven of these
self-propelled howitzers have finally
arrived on the battlefield
germany has long been accused of
dragging its heels over the delivery of
lethal aid to ukraine
to counter such criticism berlin has
released a lengthy list of weapons and
equipment it is handed over to kiev
it includes
panzerfaust infantry anti-tank rocket
launchers
man portable air defense systems or man
pads that enable soldiers to down enemy
aircraft
60 million rounds of ammunition
these deliveries proved useful in the
early stages of the war when ukrainian
forces ambushed russian columns often at
close range
but against the mass artillery deployed
by russia in its donbass offensive
ukraine needs more heavy guns of its own
germany has been slow to react unlike
some of its nato allies
the us has delivered over a hundred of
these modern artillery pieces and will
soon send long-range missile systems
poland has donated at least 18
self-propelled howitzers and hundreds of
soviet-era tanks
germany too has pledged more heavy
equipment
on the to-do list the gear pad
self-propelled anti-aircraft gun
effective against low-flying aircraft
the mars multiple launch rocket system
able to hit targets up to 80 kilometers
away
and the state-of-the-art iris-t
anti-aircraft system
able to clear the sky of enemy aircraft
and missiles
but the first batch of gay parts and the
mars launchers are only slated for
delivery in july
the iris-t might only arrive in ukraine
in october
a long wait for a country under constant
attack from the air
my next guest is nicholas drummond he's
a defense industry analyst and a former
officer in the british army mr drummond
it's good to have you with us so now
that these german this heavy weapons are
on the battlefield in ukraine
will we see a difference when it comes
to how ukraine is able to push back
the russian military
well these weapons are extremely good in
their own right uh the panzer howitzer
2000 is probably one of the most capable
uh artillery pieces in service across
nato
range of 70 kilometers with the latest
ammunition types able to deliver five
rounds on target simultaneously but
ultimately you know we're only providing
up a limited quantity of these and
really what ukraine needs is is uh is
mass
because there's no substitute for for
quantity um as well as quality and i'm
sure you're aware that
if i could let me just ask you about
these weapons and delivering them you
know the german government has been
criticized massively for how long it has
taken four months
how big of a hurdle are the logistics
here
well the it is not just the houses
themselves it's the ammunition that
supplies them
and before you can use them effectively
you have to deliver all the ammunition
that's needed and there's no point in
having how it says unless you have a
good supply of ammunition so that whole
logistics planning has to be very
carefully coordinated with the ukrainian
forces and the second really important
factor is that you have to train the
crews and this is a highly sophisticated
piece of equipment and requires
an experienced crew to use it
effectively on the battlefield so those
two factors alone will have delayed its
introduction into service irrespective
of any of the um political background to
the delivery of such weapons
we've been following you on twitter and
you have been arguing that germany's
hesitancy perhaps um to send military
support
um is
not a weakness in fact you have written
that it's a sign of integrity
why do you think so
well germany's behaved very well indeed
after the second world war it decided
that it wanted to be a country
built on economic strength not military
strength and therefore it adopted pretty
much
a pacifist mindset
and it realized that it was not going to
um sponsor a massive build build up of
weapons uh and so on
and then of course it realized that
actually
the pacifist approach
would not deter
a an adversary like russia
and schultz announced after the invasion
of ukraine by russia in february we have
to change we were wrong
we have to be strong because he only
understands strength not weakness and we
are weak if we don't invest in defense
and that was you know germany's like an
aircraft carrier it takes 10 kilometers
to turn around
and he's had to lead not only his own
party but the whole german people on
this journey and i think he's done it
with great
political dexterity
and
as far as the uk is concerned germany's
a great ally and doing extremely well
in his speech today the german
chancellor
he he said that this support for ukraine
particularly with weapons
will continue as long as the country
needs it and you know we're not talking
about um a a quick end to this war so do
you read this as germany abandoning
this it's this approach you know that
you have praised
uh no i think germany realizes now that
this is going to be a long-term
commitment
that will not change until there's a
change of government in the in russia
and not that we're not going to drive a
change of government by the way but that
will have to come from within but so
long as that regime remains in place
russia will be a threat not only to the
ukraine but to the rest of europe i mean
russia is extremely
angry putin is angry that we have
supported ukraine he thought this was
going to be a walk in the park and it's
been anything but that thanks to nato's
support of ukraine so if we don't
support ukraine if we allow russia to
win it will come after us with a
vengeance and therefore we are committed
to this for the long term for as long as
it takes
defense industry analyst nicholas
drummond mr german we appreciate your
time and your valuable insights tonight
thank you
thank you pleasure